نعم خالد بالفعل خلال ساعات الاولى كانت
الاعمال متلاشيه بايجاد اي شخص حي ويتم
انقاذه في هذا الموقع الا انه قبل قليل
فرق الانقاذ السعوديه استمعت الى صوت تم
تحديد بشكل مبدئي بانه طفل فبالتالي
بدات فرق الانقاذ بالعمل بشكل سريع جدا
على ايجاد خطط معينه للوصول الى هذا الطفل
بداوا من الجهه اليمنى من ثم انتقلوا الى
الجهه اليسرى حين وجدوا موقف للسيارات او
كراج او مدخل ليستطيعوا منه الدخول الى
الجهه الاخرى التي خرج منها صوت هذا الطفل
او المؤشرات الاوليه التي قالت بانه هنالك
صوت لطفل موجود بالاضافه الى المستشعرات
والاجهزه الحديثه التي جربتها فرق البحث
والانقاذ السعودي
رصدت ولو بنسبه ضئيله جدا ولكن تواجد شخص
بالداخل فيتم التعامل معه يعني بعض
الاشخاص المتواجدين هناك من ف انقاذ قال
بانه استمع الى صوت طفل فبالتالي يتم
التعامل مع هذه الحاله ووضع الخطط اللازمه
تغيرت الخطط بعض الشيء بدات من اليمين في
منطقه الى اليسار والان عمليات ايضا عمليه
صعبه ومعقده سيقوم فيها فريق الانقاذ من
خلال ربما خلال لحظات القليله القادمه
سيدخل احد الافراد الى هذا المدخل الذي تم
اكتشافه بشكل شخصي ليستطلع الطرق المؤديه
الى مكان الطفل في هذا الموقع قبل قليل
ايضا قبل اقل من ساعه تم طلب وضع لحظه
الصمت
لمده 20 دقيقه وايضا خلال ربما النصف ساعه
الماضيه شاهدت عدد من فرق الانقاذ تطلب
الماء للدخول الى هناك ربما الاستعداد
ايضا فرق
التركيه سياره الاسعاف تواجدت في الطرف
الاخر بعد لحظه الصمت وجود امال
بعمليه انقاذ لشخص متواجد في الداخل تم
تحديده بشكل مبدئي بانه طفل في غضون ذلك
قبل قليل تم استخراج جثه من الجهه اليسرى
وتم حملها مباشره
وايضا كان هنالك المسؤولون الاتراك في هذه
في اللحظات الماضيه كانوا قد جمعوا
الاهالي المتواجدين في الجهه الاخرى خالد
وتحدثوا معهم قليلا ربما عن هذه الجثه
التي تم استخراجها من هذا المبنى ليتم
التعرف عليها في هذا الموقع وان لم يتم
التعرف عليها يتم وضع وضعها في اماكن قبل
الذهاب بها الى المقابر الجماعيه